تقع بين جبال القوقاز العظيمة ،
تقع ميندا من ستيفان ،
وتقع المدينة على سفوح
ثالث أعلى قمة في جورجيا في جبل
كازبيك ، وهي جنة للباحثين عن الإثارة
في السنوات الأخيرة.
لاستكشاف
جورجيا ومشاعرها ، يعد Alexander s
Candra دليلًا للمغامرة وواحدًا من
رواد الطيران الشراعي
/ الطيران الشراعي في جورجيا يعد King Georgia مهمًا للغاية
لأن هدفي هو مشاركة هذه
التجربة مع أشخاص جدد مصدر إلهام لأشخاص
لاستكشاف Turgeon بطريقة مختلفة في وقت مبكر من
بعد الظهر حيث تختار الرياح  حان الوقت
لأذهب إلى السماء
عندما أكون محترفًا في التزحلق ، أشعر بالحرية فقط
لأنني أستطيع التحكم في السرعة التي يمكنني
التحكم بها في الفضاء الذي
بدأ عندما كان عمره 16 عامًا ، لقد حصل على
علة الطيران من جدته إلى
الستينيات التي كانت عليها  كانت قافزة مظلات في جورجيا
كانت تبلغ من العمر 23 عامًا في هذا الوقت
كانت تجربة فريدة جدًا خاصة
بالنسبة للنساء حيث يأتي عدد متزايد من
السياح القادمين  إلى جورجيا على
وجه التحديد للمظلات ، أحدها هو
استئجار كريستين غيش من النمسا ،
وهناك الكثير لاستكشافه هنا ، حيث يعد الطيران المظلي في
سريراتشا أمرًا خاصًا لأنه
لا يزال بلدًا متقدمًا وقد أصبحنا
مهتمين للغاية لأننا اكتشفنا
الجبال العالية مثل 5000 متر مثل
ينتهي يوم الطيران
ويخمد اندفاع الأدرينالين ،
ويبقى أليكس متعة أخيرة هي
الجلوس والاستمتاع بمنظر هذه
الجبال الوعرة ،
جورجيا مذهلة لأن هنا
كل شيء برية مدهشة لجميع
الأنشطة